Sollen wir heute in ein Restaurant gehen?
Oh ja, das ist eine gute Idee.
Worauf hast du Lust?
Ich habe heute Lust auf Pizza.
Ich möchte heute Italienisch essen.
Komm wir gehen zum Italiener.
Magst du chinesisches Essen?
Ja. Ich mag chinesisches Essen.
Ich esse gerne Dim-Sum.
Nein. Ich mag kein chinesisches Essen.
Es ist mir zu salzig.
Kann ich dir etwas zu Essen anbieten?
Ja, ich habe ein bisschen Hunger.
Ja, ich esse gerne etwas.
Nein, danke, ich habe keinen Hunger.
Nein, danke, ich habe schon gegessen.
Nein, danke.
Ich habe später eine Verabredung zum Essen.
Lass uns hier am Imbisstand etwas bestellen.
Ich bestelle einen Hamburger.
Was ist heute das vegetarische Gericht?
Ich esse kein Fleisch.
Ich bin Vegetarier / Ich bin Vegetarierin.
Ich esse keine tierischen Produkte.
Ich bin Veganer.
Ich gehe zum Bäcker.
Wir haben kein Brot mehr.
Gemüse und Obst enthalten viele Vitamine.
Nudeln bestehen aus Getreide.
Mit dem Mehl backt man Brot.
Lass uns etwas zusammen kochen.
Ich habe heute im Supermarkt eingekauft.
Es hat viele Lebensmittel im Kühlschrank.
Wir müssen sie essen, sonst verderben sie.
Nein, Ich möchte heute nicht kochen.
Bestellen wir doch etwas beim Lieferdienst.
Heute möchten wir im Garten grillen.
Wir grillen leckere Hühnerschenkel.
Isst du gerne Sushi?
Ja. Ich esse gern Sushi.
Nein. Ich esse nicht gern Sushi.
Ich mag keinen Fisch.
Magst du mexikanisches Essen?
Ja. Ich liebe Tacos.
Nein. Mexikanisches Essen ist mir zu scharf.
Ich habe eine Nussallergie.
Mein Körper reagiert
allergisch auf Schalenfrüchte.
Ich soll keine Meeresfrüchte essen.
Wenn ich ein Gericht esse, das Nüsse enthält,...
bekomme ich Probleme beim Atmen.
Möchtest du etwas essen?
Ja, ich möchte Nudeln essen.
Ja, ich hätte gern etwas süsses.
Nein, ich bin auf Diät.
Nein, ich möchte nichts essen.
Was möchtest du essen.
Ich möchte einen Hot Dog essen.
Ich hätte gern einen Hamburger.
Hmm, ich weiss es nicht.
Was möchtest du denn essen?
Hast du Lust auf Kuchen?
Ja, ich habe Lust auf Kuchen.
Ich nehme gern ein Stück Kuchen.
Nein, ich habe eher Lust auf Pudding.
Darf ich Ihnen etwas zu Essen anbieten?
Das ist sehr nett von Ihnen.
Sehr gern Vielen Dank.
Sehr nett, aber ich habe leider keinen Hunger.
Was hättest du gern zu essen?
Ich hätte gern ein Schnitzel mit Pommes.
Ich hätte gern ein Steak mit Salat.
Was hast du bestellt?
Ich habe eine Kirschtorte bestellt.
Ich habe Pfannkuchen bestellt.
Was ist sein Lieblingsessen?
Mein Lieblingsessen ist Hühnchen mit Pommes.
Mein Lieblingsessen ist die Bratwurst.
Ich habe jetzt Hunger bekommen.
Ich möchte jetzt mein Hähnchen essen.
Was ist dein Lieblingsessen?
Was würdest du jetzt gern essen?
Schreib bitteeinen Kommentar mit deinem Lieblingsgericht.
Abonniere den Kanal der Hallo Deutschschule.
Aktiviere das kleine Glöckchen.
Gib uns jetzt einen Daumen nach oben.
Klicke aufdiese Playlist um weitere Videos zu sehen.